brandon woodruff his second start
against philadelphia rock his second
start against zach wheeler this year no
kidding zach wheeler beat him in early
may was a two to nothing complete game
shutout for wheeler but
would your pitch well he's second league
in earned run average second and
opponent batting average
fifth in strikeouts you get the point i
mean he's been outstanding he's won two
in a row he beat the giants his last
timeout
all set again and for herrera here he
comes swinging in a fly ball hit to very
shallow
sutter and waiting is
jackie bradley jr there's one up and one
down here's bryce harper that's with a
man aboard
that ball's hit well out to center field
bradley going back and it is gone
just over the toyota territory sign
bryce harper is 28th home run has given
the phils a two-nothing lead oh baby
that sounded good off the bat and by the
way heck of a catch by the fan out in
right center fields
and a swing at him as he got him and
woodruff gets him struck him out
rounding out the starting nine that'll
face the phillies ace
zach wheeler man this guy's something
else 27 starts already this year and
he's got three complete games one of
them against the brewers
1-2 out towards center not deep
going out as deedy coming in as o'double
and herrera makes the catch
wiener ready to pitch
swinging a papa this one's shadow left
going out galves and deedy and didi
gregorius the shortstop under it he'll
make the catch
swig of the miss 99 on the fastball and
wheeler picks up the strikeout
swinging a bouncer hit to colton wong
and he better hurry and just did get him
and the 01 delivery bouncer hit near
second that's
for the shortstop louise urias
here is freddy freddy who had a big home
run yesterday
3-2 again and it's swung on hit high in
the air to right field it's pretty well
hit peterson going back at the track at
the wall it is gone and freddie galvez
with a towering home run down the right
field line and what an at-bat for freddy
and the phillies now lead it three to
nothing against woodruff
and he hits that one sharply to right
almost in his tracks peterson makes a
play
line drive to left that'll be in for a
hit and then segura goes to second he's
thinking about third there he goes the
throw off the glove of escobar
and the phillies have first and third
actually
real muto
went to second base on that throw that's
excellent base running yeah with two in
scoring position mccutchen is up one and
two the count on mccutchen infield in
and a swing at a miss he got a game
changing at bat right here didi
gregorius second and third with two away
infield backs up the delivery
swinging a fly ball to shadow left
christian yelich has a beat on it makes
the catch and for the first time this
afternoon woodruff puts up a zero
against the phillies
[Music]
a little tapper out in front of the
plate into getting weiner bare hand pick
froze to first
check on the swing but couldn't hold up
no balls and a strike to count wong at
first peterson up the middle of base
head
and just like that the tying runs coming
to the plate in the form of christian
yelich
[Applause]
a bouncer right side miller fields it
and tags yelich out
and that will wrap up the bottom of the
third miller 4 for 11 on the road trip
that ball's hit well out toward right
field peterson's going back no doubt
about it second deck home run for brad
miller he crushed it his 16th of the
year it's the second solo home run of
the day for the fills their third homer
overall and it's now four nothing what a
beautiful swing from brad miller
a wind-up in the 0-1 pitch swaying and a
high pop-up
right side segura in the shadows he's
looking up into the blue wisconsin sky
he'll make the catch
fly ball right field right at harper now
he comes in
on the outside corner got it with a hook
fifth strike out of the day for zach
wheeler three and two now and that one's
right down the middle harper
chops it on the ground a little roll
over bouncer to teles
and real muto lines one caught by
escobar
sun shining down on him escobar
with a nice backhanded play for out
number two
another one-two and a swing at a miss he
buckled in
2-2 pitch to bradley
broke his bat out to right
caught by harper
2-2 pitch coming
swinging a miss and he got him with a
slider
zach's got the pitch he wants and the
3-2
breaking ball swung on it missed seven
strikeouts for wheeler
back toward the middle and fielded by
wheeler a little underhand toss
swag in a miss escobar goes after one up
in the zone eight strikeouts for wheeler
the one-two pitch swing of the vince
struck him out
and zach winter another strikeout to his
ledger ninth k of the day
and the bases are loaded with bryce
harper coming up sooner deals harper
takes a call strike three ring him up
so that brings up jt romuto you've got
thereas at third oh dublin second segura
at first
on the ground got a chance here flip it
throw it
double play
out of the inning
brent sooner fired up on his way to the
dugout
the pinch hit game-winning grand slam
last night for daniel vogelback nearest
against vogelback
swag gonna miss he got him threw him
another splitter phillies with a four to
nothing lead box burger against andrew
mccutchen he swings at the first pitch
hits it high in the air deep left center
field yelling's going back looking up
and it is gone into the brewer bullpen
and andrew mccutchen who had to be
delighted that he was not facing brandon
woodruff he's got a first pitch homer
off of brad boxberger his 24th of the
year it's five nothing in phillies and
that will load the bases for the second
hitting in a row the phillies have the
bases loaded with nobody out
ground ball past the diving escobar into
left field one run will score the hold
up miller rbi single for tires who's two
for two today
on the mountain count is owen two
herrera hits it back to the mound he
goes to second and it's bobbled by uria
said everybody is safe i don't know why
he didn't go home for that one i have no
idea
seven nothing phillies and here's segura
batting with the bases loaded it was hit
hard enough that ball is hit well down
the left field line it is gone
grand slam for gene segora
and the phillies lead it 11-0 and he
wants the baseball
gene segura turns on one it's his third
hit of the day 400 feet
wow
knuckle ball hit in the air to right
field going back on it is peterson
toward the wall it is gone
it's another multi-home run game for
brad miller
[Applause]
ground ball back up the middle he
glances off the pitcher more picked up
by torreira's his throw to first is in
time how about that oh my goodness
how do you get that much on that throw
that'll complete the shutout a one five
three put out